se me ocurre pensar que ya sé cuánto
vale esta área esta área que tengo justo
aquí es decir si tengo que esta es la
curva que es igual a fx ok entonces
sabemos que está esta área que tengo
aquí la podemos denotar como la integral
definida desde a hasta bbb de fx de x y
en esta ocasión voy a suponer que ya sé
cuánto vale esto se me ocurre pensar que
va a ser exactamente igual a 5 a 5 muy
bien suponiendo esto antes de cambiar de
color que te parece si pensamos en
cuánto va a valer la siguiente integral
ahora quiero fijarme en la integral ok
de f
de f de x menos ok de x de x ok desde
hace desde ambas ok hasta de más hasta
de más es decir
dada esta integral que tengo justo aquí
como puedo relacionar estas dos
integrales estas dos expresiones y bueno
esto es ganar bastante rimbombante sin
embargo
te voy a pedir de favor que intentes
pausar el video y no se puede tomar
algunas m y tal vez graficando o tratar
de visualizarlo en tu mente intenta
pensar cuánto va a ser esto con respecto
a esta que tengo aquí bueno asumiendo
que ya pausa hasta el vídeo y cuéntame
cómo se ven
efe de x bueno pues si recuerdas fx - m
es exactamente esta gráfica solamente
que desplazada hacia la derecha se
unidades pues vamos a hacerlo sí para
que atraigan esta gráfica de aquí y la
desplazó sea unidades no sé se me ocurre
pensar que han por acá por aquí vamos a
suponer que es 11 unidades es decir si
yo me fijo en esta distancia de que
hasta acá voy a suponer que son c
unidades es más déjenme bajar un poco
más esta gráfica un poco más esta
gráfica y voy a suponer que de aquí acá
tengo ce unidades
si yo dibujo con este color esta gráfica
que tengo aquí
déjame traerla como por acá ok
después vamos a seguir estando la como
por acá ok y ahora voy a subir hasta acá
bueno pues esta de aquí nosotros sabemos
que esta gráfica de color verde es lo
mismo que yo es igual a efe de x - c ya
la tenemos justo aquí es decir que lo
único que hice fue desplazar a esta
gráfica hasta acá se unidades c unidades
ok no está tan difícil lo único que hice
fue desplazar esta gráfica de aquí hasta
acá
unidades hasta acá se unidades y
seguramente esto es algo que aprendiste
en sus clases de pre cálculo o en tus
clases de álgebra por ejemplo y bueno
una forma fácil de ver esto para que sea
mucho más sencillo es pensar en el valor
de x igual hace cuando x vale se bueno
pues date cuenta aunque lo único que
estamos haciendo es moviéndonos hasta
acá ok a este valor de s supongamos que
es éste de por aquí
ok y entonces deberíamos de tomar justo
el mismo valor déjame subir por acá
deberíamos de tomar justo el mismo valor
que tomamos cuando nosotros teníamos en
nuestra grafía
fx el valor de x igual a 0 y si te das
cuenta es exactamente lo mismo
x igual a 0 cuando nosotros teníamos la
función original llegábamos a este punto
de aquí y si lo desplazamos c veces
llegamos a este punto de aquí cuando x
balesem en esta gráfica de verde bueno y
ahora qué te parece si pensamos en los
límites de evaluación am aquí necesito a
maze bueno aquí tengo a am si le sumo
bueno me voy a llegar hasta por acá más
o menos como por acá va a ser algo hasta
acá ok aquí tengo a más a más c y si
después me fijo en bmc bueno pues a b
habrá que sumarle la misma distancia que
nos movimos queda se es más o menos como
por acá llegamos a este valor ok voy a
suponer que aquí tengo ve más cm estoy
cambiando a mis nuevos límites de
integración ok
así que cambiemos de color y vamos a
utilizar el color amarillo si me fijo en
mis nuevos límites de integración déjame
subir para cada dejarme subir para acá
ok
llegar aquí ok de lujo y ahora tengo
este equipo ok antes que subir para acá
ok y voy a fijarme en el área más y que
esto lo voy a poner de color amarillo ok
déjame atraparlo de color amarillo para
que lo veas justo aquí si yo me fijo en
esta área que ahora tengo representada
justo aquí en esta área que tengo
representada justo aquí que está entre
mis límites ok
esta que tengo justo aquí bueno pues
creo que te estás dando cuenta a dónde
vamos a llegar y es que está genial
porque lo que hicimos fue desplazar
hacia la derecha la función desplazamos
hacia la derecha los valores de los
límites de integración y entonces date
cuenta que tenemos la misma área es
decir que esto va a ser exactamente
igual que nuestra área original que era
esta de aquí es decir la integral desde
amd hasta bm de fx de fx de x que bueno
en este caso yo había dicho que era 5
solamente para tomarnos un ejemplo
particular pero lo importante es justo
este resultado al que acaba
de llegar esto es como un truco de las
matemáticas tú te lo puedes encontrar no
sé en algún examen de cálculo o en
competiciones de matemáticas o tal vez
en algún examen muy difícil pero
realmente esto te va a ayudar bastante a
que los vuelvas integrales por ejemplo
si tú tienes un problema bastante
bastante interesante y bueno de hecho
este tipo de problemas vamos a resolver
en un futuro entonces si nosotros
identificamos este caso va a ser mucho
más fácil nuestra evaluación si por
ejemplo vemos algo así decimos se ve un
poco difícil como lo voy a resolver
bueno pues ya sabes que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que desplazar tu
área original de unidades lo único que
estamos haciendo es desplazar a nuestra
función original y por lo tanto vamos a
llegar al mismo resultado